Da steht der noch.
So exquisite, Leute wie sieht es aus, wer war heute vom Bahnstreik betroffen?
Musste ich hier mal mit den Bebegas auseinandersetzen.
Kann wieder streamen, ja jetzt wo ich weniger verdiene post ab muss ich natürlich auch
mehr streamen ist ja klar.
Obvious, lass das Haus nicht verlassen, doch, also lustigerweise seit ich Homeoffice mache
bewege ich mich sogar mehr.
Ich bin nicht mehr so kaputt durch hin und zurück und auf der Arbeit ungedulds machen.
Ich bin nicht mehr so kaputt, deswegen kann ich so eine Stunde, eineinhalb Stunden auch
ein bisschen Sport machen mittags.
Sport für meine Verhältnisse, Sport, andere würden sagen Keg Weight, ist doch kein Sport,
aber trotzdem ich bewege mich mehr als wenn ich arbeiten muss.
Übrigens soll ich euch mal zeigen was ich heute Mittag gegessen habe, Leute die auf
Twitter am Start sind haben es eh schon gesehen, aber heute gab es richtig massiv Köfteteller.
Achso übrigens, Katzlicht neuerdings im Waschbecken.
Da sieht man mal wie dick die Katze ist, guckt euch mal an wie dick die Katze eigentlich
ist.
Das fällt sonst immer gar nicht auf, weil die sich so ausstreckt, aber die ist schon
ganz schön fett.
Ist aber noch kein Hase, so, jetzt wollte ich euch mal was anderes zeigen, guckt mal.
Huge Döner Teller, äh nicht Döner Teller, Köfteteller, Hochformat ich weiß, Painz
Champ, aber ist der nicht Pock, guckt den euch mal an hier, hättet ihr richtig Bock
drauf könntest du da nochmal futtern.
Massive Döner Teller, das ist eigentlich für zwei Personen, was man hier sieht ist
wie gesagt ist eigentlich für zwei Personen, aber ich musste, ich musste bestellen, weil
es hatte ja einen 15 Euro Mindestbestellwert.
Leak in der Gabel, ja, was ist das rechteste, du meinst das, das ist das, das ich glaube
Börek heißt das oder Börek, ich weiß nicht wie man das richtig ausspricht, die Türken
rollen das, rollen das eher immer so gerne, was heißt das Börek oder so, guck mal Aussprache,
nein.
Pronunciation, nicht Börek, spricht man das aus, in, in, in türkisch, genau, in, in,
in dänisch, ok, Börek, Börek, na, weiß ich doch gar nicht, weiß ich doch gar nicht
so weit, so weit weg davon oder, aber ich stelle relativ lange dran.
Börek ist mein Arbeitskollege, ja ich glaube vom Namen her hat er damit auch nicht so viel
zu tun, ist aber echt nice, also ich habe, wie gesagt ich habe nicht alles gefuttert,
ich habe den Salat gegessen, weil sagt die Mutter schon immer Salat ist wichtig, Pommes
frites war halt dabei, ich habe eigentlich nur den Döner Teller gefuttert und die Hälfte
davon dann, dann war fertig, aber trotzdem richtig, richtig nice, bei dem bestelle ich
öfters.
So und dann, und dann Leute wollte ich euch noch was anderes zeigen, schaut mal her,
die Bahn ist richtig advanced, die suchen jetzt nicht einfach nur DevOps Leute, die Bahn suchen
jetzt bis DevOps, ich weiß gar nicht wie man das aussprechen soll, Business DevOps, also
das ist dann quasi ein Programmierer der Excel kann oder wie, oder aber, oder aber
vielleicht, vielleicht schwebt der Bahn sowas vor, BizepsOps genau, vielleicht, vielleicht
schwebt der Bahn sowas vor, ein ehemaliger Admin der gut programmieren kann, hat irgendwann
mal BWL studiert, man weiß ja nicht was die Bahn sich darunter vorstellt, was Twitter
Trends in Nacktbilder, da kann ich jetzt nicht, da kann ich jetzt nicht drauf, drauf, alter
was sind das denn wieder für Trends in Deutschland, deutsche Trends, Pädophile, Gottesdienste,
Gender Nein Danke, Nacktbilder, BioNTech, da willst du ja auf nix draufklicken, wieviel
später kommt der Chainlord, ich glaube das hängt davon ab, wie langsam der Discord Bot
ist, alter Chat reißt euch zusammen, aber die Trends, ich wills mir gar nicht angucken,
deswegen hab ich meine Trends auf Andorra gestellt, da muss ich mich da mit den Trends
nicht auseinandersetzen, ja aber kann irgendjemand eine Idee was das sein soll, also ich hab
die Bahn ja gefragt, Ed Bahn und Debbie Systelle, die haben natürlich nicht drauf geantwortet,
ich hab ehrlich gesagt gehofft die Antworten drauf, weil die Bahn antwortet gerne auf Twitter,
aber ich hab das Gefühl die wissen das selber nicht was das sein soll, die Bahn, du musstest
heute eine 100km Zugstrecke fahren, alle Bahnen sind ausgefallen bis auf eine, die wurde 5
Minuten lang gecancelt, Fils Batman, ich hab heute geguckt, der Zug mit dem ich normal
gefahren wäre ist auch ausgefallen, aber zum Glück heute wieder Massive Home Office, ok
du hast das von irgendwo copy pasted, aber der Nachteil an solchen Erklärungen ist,
die sagen ja eigentlich gar nichts aus, also wenn da jetzt steht, bis Dev Ops ist eine
agile Software Entwicklungs Methode, Methode triffts ja nicht so genau, Verfahren oder
was heißt das direkt übersetzt auf Deutsch, Methodik, genau, ist eine agile Software Entwicklungs
Methodik, die befürwortet mehr Kommunikation und Zusammenarbeit zwischen Business, Entwicklung
und Admin Teams durch den Software Life Cycle, das ist so komplett nichts sagend, ja ich
weiß dass ich das, dass ich das aus Business, Development und Operations zusammensetz darauf
wäre ich jetzt auch noch gekommen, also ganz so 3 Head bin ich ja nett, aber was genau
soll uns das sagen, also die Bahnstellen Anzeige ergibt auch keinen Sinn, also der
App Store sagt keinen Sinn, die erklären das nicht, Max was nutzt ihr auch als Ticketsystem
intern, Gyra, genau so geschrieben wie es ausgesprochen wird, also nur eine neue Stufe
der Basswörter, korrekt, korrekt, was anderes ist das nicht, neues, neues, genau Gyra,
so geschrieben wie es ausgesprochen wird, Atlassian Gyra, das ist für die coolen Leute
die auch Ubuntu, Ubuntu, Ubuntu, Ubuntu aussprechen, laut Golemberich das habe ich
auch gelesen, also Hira, was war glaube ich wirklich Gyra oder so, man spricht das, das
ist japanisch und man spricht das irgendwie anders aus als man es japanisch erwarten
würde, das habe ich mir gemerkt, laut Golemberich bis zu 25 Sprüche, da geht gerade richtig
was ab, Apple oder was, ich glaube Apple oder was, also bei Apple ist ja richtig die Kacke
am dampfen gerade was Home Office angeht, die Leute wollen ja, da habe ich ja ein Video
schon mal zu gemacht vor einem Monat oder so, die Leute wollen nicht und die haben das
glaube ich jetzt auch verschoben auf nächstes Jahr oder Microsoft, ich kriege es gerade
aus dem Kopf nicht mehr zusammen, zumindest einer dieser großen hat es jetzt komplett
verschoben auf nächstes Jahr und Apple sagt auch die Leute dürfen in Zukunft nicht mehr
über das Gehalt reden, was ich auch lustig fand, Apple Gehalt, Moment, pass mal auf,
das muss ich mal, News, ja, Tim Gachibas verbessert sein Gehalt, das wundert mich nicht, Apple
verbietet den Mitarbeitern den Vergleich über ihre Gehälter, genau, das habe ich heute auch
wegen einer anderen News Seite gelesen, ich weiß nicht genau wo, das ist was ich auch
lustig finde, es gab ja bei uns teilweise Arbeitgeber, also in Deutschland, die das
probiert haben, in den Arbeitsvertrag zu schreiben, dass die Leute nicht über ihr Geld sprechen
dürfen, allerdings ist das ja nicht wirksam, darfst du ja gar nicht, deswegen bin ich froh,
früher war es bei uns auch so, ich habe ja auch letztes Mal im Video gesagt, also früher
war es bei uns auch, Notebook Check, was ist das eigentlich für eine komische Seite, gab
es das nicht auf Heise irgendwie so, Apple, Apple interne Umfragen, genau, das habe ich
vorhin auch gelesen, so und was wollte ich jetzt sagen, genau, deswegen bin ich ja froh,
dass es bei uns mittlerweile sich bei den Leuten so durchgesetzt hat, dass es eigentlich auch
okay ist, wenn man darüber redet, ich meine, man muss sich jetzt nicht in die Kaffeeküche
stellen, erzählen, ich habe Gehaltserkündigung gekriegt, so und so viel ist das jetzt und
so und so viel Bonus und bla bla bla, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel, das Gute,
aber bei uns reden die Leute mittlerweile untereinander und da bin ich ja wirklich froh, dass sich
das jetzt etabliert hat, als ich angefangen habe, war das noch so nach dem Motto, haha,
ich habe gut verhandelt, ich sage dir nicht, wie viel ich kriege und so was, das fand
ich damals schon merkwürdig, aber ich habe mich damals davon insofern beeindrucken lassen,
weil es halt quasi Leute, die älter waren und länger dabei waren als ich, immer so gesagt
haben und da habe ich gedacht, okay komisch, weil ich hätte gerade damals, wo die mich
beim Provider damals übernommen haben, hätte ich schon gerne mal gewusst, was verdienen
die Leute eigentlich so, dass ich dann auch hätte sagen können, okay für so wenig habe
ich da keinen Bock drauf, ja und wie gesagt, also bei uns ist es jetzt relativ normal,
dass die Leute zumindest auf die Frage antworten, ja und ich habe, ich meine, ich habe ein komplettes
Video drüber gemacht und ich habe auch keinen Bock, äh, was soll ich sagen, ich muss da,
wie gesagt, ich muss da auch nicht laufen drüber reden, aber ich habe keine Probleme, wenn mich
jemand fragt und umgedreht ist das bei uns auch ganz okay, ja in Stellenanzeigen, wisst
ihr was, das verstehe ich auch nicht so genau, in Stellenanzeigen, Moment, Apple hat ein
größeres Problem, ja das ist ja, das haben wir letzten Sonntag besprochen, das ist ja
ganz eigenes Ding, das ist ja kein Problem nur in Deutschland, vielleicht bei uns besonders,
ich weiß es nicht, aber diese Sachen mit über mein Gehalt rede ich nicht, das ist ja generell
irgendwie verbreitet, weiß nicht warum das so ein Ding ist, ich glaube ja, das liegt
ein bisschen daran, also meine persönliche Vermutung ist, man möchte nicht, dass man
zugeben muss, also wenn mich einer fragt, man möchte nicht, dass man als derjenige
da steht, der weniger verdient, ich glaube, das wollen viele, dabei ist das ja eigentlich
ein Trugschluss, selbst wenn das jetzt so ist, es ist ja gut, dass man das erfährt,
auch wenn es vielleicht erst mal doof ist, weil man sich denkt, ich mach doch viel mehr
als die anderen, aber dann kann man das nächste Mal auch sagen, okay, jetzt weiß ich was
hier möglich ist und wahrscheinlich ist sogar noch eine ganze Ecke mehr möglich, die bezahlen
mich einfach zu schlecht, genau, also genau, sehe ich genauso, naja, aber sag mal so, ich
fände es schon nicht verkehrt, wenn man zumindest mal ein bisschen, weiß ich so eine Hausnummer
vielleicht irgendwie raushaut, also ich hätte auch kein Problem, wenn sie das ganz weglassen,
aber es schreibt doch jeder mittlerweile, so was rein wie, äh, wir bieten ein überdurchschnittliches
Gehalt, das ist halt so komplett nichtssagend, dann sollen sie halt wenigstens noch mal ein
bisschen Details reinschreiben, was die denn unter überdurchschnittlichem Gehalt, die
müssen ja keine exakte Zahl reinschreiben, aber die schreiben, die tun alle immer so,
als sind sie krassen Gönner und dann kommt dann am Ende raus 25k im Jahr oder so, obwohl
es dann keiner Bock hat, wo hast du das geschickt, auf Twitter, nee, äh, hier, warte mal, wenn
ich da was zensieren muss, mach du das mal, ich weiß nicht, wo das alles steht, mach
du das mal, mach du mal alles schwarz, was geschwärzt werden muss, natürlich zeige
ich das hier im Stream, also das heißt, ich werde jetzt alles ignorieren, was jetzt gekommen
ist, weiß ich wo du das geschickt hast, auf Twitter hab ich nichts gesehen, hast du per
Mail geschickt, mal gucken, mach alles schwarz und schick das nochmal, also das alles weg
ist, ich will nicht daran schuld sein, wenn da irgendwas geleakt wird hier jetzt, nö,
ich hab nix gekriegt, ah Moment, Moment, Moment, Probe Klausur Wirtschaftsinformatik, ja, hab
mich gekriegt, ähm, ich werde das ignorieren jetzt an der Stelle, ich werfe das auch mal
in Papierkorb, schick mir das nochmal und mach alles schwarz, weil, sonst, sonst zeige
ich da irgendwas, irgendwas im Stream, weiß ich nicht, ich will es, dass man das zeigt.
So, ok, dann, ja, ist so, was hältst du von Doktor Disrespect, ich hab von Doktor Disrespect
weder eine, irgendwie besonders gute oder besonders schlechte Meinung, ich hab Doktor Disrespect
nie geschaut, ich hab paar Clips geschaut, wo ich mich gefragt hab, ok, warum das die
Leute jetzt so krass feiern, verstehe ich nicht, dann hab ich ein paar andere Clips
geschaut, da muss ich sagen, das war schon ganz lustig, aber ich glaube, ich wäre nie
der größte, also wenn er noch auf Twitch wäre nie der größte Doktor Disrespect Fan
geworden, ich kann dazu aber gar nichts sagen, ich gucke einfach, ich hab das zu wenig geguckt,
du hast ein höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch, ja, hab ich, und welche Tools sind ein Must
Have auf deinem Desk, Mathe-ETC, meinem Desk, hier stehen, also du meinst jetzt mal, Nebenmonitor
und sonst was aus, gut, mein Audio Interface, aber das ist ja keine Tools, hab eigentlich
nix, ich hab ne Tastatur, ich hab das Mousepad, was die Maus auflädt, ich hab hier diese
Logitech Mouse Kombi, diese, was ist, G Pro Wireless oder so, also sprich diese Maus mit
dem Mousepad, die das per Induktion oder was auch immer die Maus auflädt, dann liegt
noch ne zweite Maus für den zweiten Rechner drauf, zwei Boxen für Musik, die ich selten
an hab, ich hab meist Kopfhörer auf, zwei Kopfhörer und das Audio Interface und ansonsten
liegt da nichts großartig drauf, ich hab keinen Monitorhalter, die stehen bei mir einfach
auf nem ganz normalen Monitor, Ständer, der dabei ist, ja, eigentlich nix, irgendwie speziell
ist, ok, also ich würd sagen wir machen jetzt da weiter, laut deiner Statistik Streams heute,
wieso, was sagt denn die Statistik, sagt die Statistik, ich streame nie am Mittwoch,
übrigens die Leute haben sich heut mal wieder heftig, wieder richtig heftig chibänen lassen
auf Twitter von mir, ah tatsächlich, streame Mittwoch wenig, also wieder richtig, richtig
chibänen lassen, guckt euch das mal an, so, die meisten haben es gecheckt, ich hab mir
gedacht, ich muss mal wieder den IT Mythos, der Vater aller IT Mythen rauskramen, ja,
und da kamen tatsächlich Leute, die geschrieben haben, das ist ein Mythos, jockey da, richtig
five hand moment, dabei wissen wir das, alle, dass das menschliche Auge nur 12 FPS sieht,
Weserhalter sind vor allem die für Apple für 300 Euro oder sowas, heute war Samsung Event,
falls es jemand interessiert, neue Galaxy Watch, dann mal auf den Sensoren, Wear OS,
statt Titsen, kein Titsen mehr, neues Z-Fold Flip 3, gut, ich hab so keinen Plan von Samsung
Dinger, ich weiß nur, dass, ne Moment, nicht Samsung, ich bringe die Krause, habt ihr mitbekommen,
dass Xiaomi gespendet hat, Spende für die Flutopfer, weiß ich ob ihr das gelesen habt,
wisst ihr was ich daran cool fand, also vielleicht ist es jetzt schon wieder verwerflich was
dazu zu sagen, weiß man ja heute nie, aber was ich sehr interessant fand ist, dass jetzt
die Chinesen für uns spenden, ich hab damit ja, also ich will nicht sagen, dass ich damit
ein Problem hab wenn die spenden, aber in der Vergangenheit haben wir eigentlich immer
Entwicklungshilfe nach China geschickt und wenn da irgendwas war, humanitäre Unterstützung
geleistet und sonst was und jetzt ist es soweit, wir müssen uns quasi von den Chinesen was
spenden lassen, da sieht man denke ich mal auch wohin die Fahrt geht, die sieht man denke
ich mal auch wohin die Fahrt geht, die Chinesen haben nicht nur aufgeholt, die machen demnächst
hier Abfahrt an uns vorbei, ok vielleicht ist es ein bisschen viel rein interpretiert
in Chinesen spenden uns was, aber trotzdem, ich finds interessant, wir haben da vor ein
paar Jahren quasi noch Entwicklungshilfe bezahlt und heute kriegen wir spenden aus China, von
den China Chinesen, gucken wie sich das entwickelt, ich bin da wirklich gespannt, Deutschland
sendet immer noch 500 Millionen Entwicklungshilfe nach China, ja dann, da können die uns auch
mal eine Million zurück überweisen oder, bald chinesische Entwicklungshilfe Support
beim Breitband ausbauen, also ich glaube eh, dass wir uns mit den Chinesen demnächst ganz
gut austauschen können, die Chinesen machen für uns Technik und Internetausbau und wir
machen demnächst Zensur für die Chinesen, also in einem Thema holen wir auch relativ
gut auf, wenn diese Sachen mit das komplette Internetwit zur Whitelist durch Altersfreigabe
für jede nur erdenkliche Seite durchkommt, da steht die chinesische Delegation vor der
Tür und sagt, sagt ihr mal Jungs, könnt ihr uns erklären wie ihr das gemacht habt,
wir tun uns da viel schwerer, denn dann machen wir demnächst Zensur in China und die Chinesen
machen bei uns Internetausbau, das wäre doch mal eine gute Kombination oder, hab ich gesehen
ja, was hältst du davon, dass ab nächsten Monat öffentliche Testen Geld kostet, boah,
ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich hab bisher ein bisschen ignoriert mit den Gedanken drüber
zu machen, die, ich kann es ja mal kurz im Stream machen, also kein Anspruch auf irgendwie
tiefere Überlegungen, also ich mach mir jetzt wirklich zum ersten Mal Gedanken drüber,
also ich hab es die letzten Tage ein bisschen ignoriert, weil es ja wieder sehr hoch hergegangen
ist auf Twitter, also das erste was mir so im Kopf kommt ist, ich verstehe den Sinn nicht,
warum stellt man das jetzt ein, ich mein auf der einen Seite heißt es ja, es ist noch
gefährlich und auf der anderen Seite möchte man es jetzt nicht mehr bezahlen, das sind
noch zwei Sachen, die sich widersprechen oder, also entweder ist die Gefahr vorbei,
dann muss man die Leute auch nicht mehr zum Testen ermuntern oder, die Gefahr besteht
noch, dann muss man den Leuten auch, dass sie sich testen und man dadurch feststellt,
wer was hat, den Test einschweiter bezahlen, dadurch lässt sich doch keiner zum Impfen
zwingen oder, wobei das ja eigentlich, selbst wenn es dazu da wäre, die Leute zum Impfen
zu zwingen, dann wäre es doch eigentlich total kontraproduktiv oder, weil die Leute,
die Hardcore keinen Bock auf Impfen haben, die werden sich doch jetzt da trotzdem nicht
impfen lassen und man merkt später, wenn die was haben, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass das Leute motiviert sich impfen zu lassen, die müssen trotzdem, also ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen, dass das wirklich Leute motiviert sich testen zu lassen, auf der anderen Seite
kommt ja damit das, also wenn du versuchst damit Druck auszuüben, kommt ja auf der anderen
Seite das, was man am Anfang von Corona strikt abgelehnt hat, dass man nämlich gesagt hat,
dass, ich überlege gerade, wie man das formuliert hat, dass es quasi eine Pflicht sich zu testen
gibt, um quasi Grundrechte zurückzuerlangen, es hat ja auch Testpflicht und sonst was wild
getrendet auf Twitter die letzten Tage, deswegen habe ich das Thema ignoriert, weil es da ultra
heiß hoch geht, aber wenn man sowas macht, um Leute zum Impfen zu zwingen, weil sie sonst
ihr Leben nicht mehr leben können, dann ist das ja eigentlich eine Impfpflicht, also wenn
ich mal das Argument, was die jetzt im Chat gesagt haben, weiter denke, dann heißt es
ja nach dem Motto, man würde das machen, um die Leute quasi zu zwingen sich impfen zu
lassen, weil die ihr tägliches Leben nicht mehr ausüben können oder halt extrem viel
Geld ausgeben müssen und dann wäre es ja quasi so eine Art Testpflicht, ja und außerdem
was dann auch noch dabei kommt, jetzt wenn ich mir das gerade mal so überlege, wie gesagt
ich müsste mir da noch ein bisschen tiefgreifender Gedanken machen, aber wenn ich mir das jetzt
so überlege, heißt das ja auch, übrigens nächste Woche habe ich mal eine zweite Impfung
dran, das habe ich nicht vergessen, was auch noch dazu kommt ist, dass das gerade mal wieder
die Leute spaltet in arm und reich, also sagen wir jetzt mal ein reicher Impfgegner hat damit
weniger Probleme als ein armer Impfgegner, ein reicher Impfgegner kann sich die Tests
leisten, wenn er das machen muss und armer Impfgegner nicht, zweite ist nicht so schlimm,
ja ich habe gehört, Bio und Tech zweite Runde soll ein bisschen mehr reinhauen, aber ich
war mir da keine Gedanken, sagt ein FDP, ja und, ist einer normaler nichts zu tun, also
das wird ja auf jeden Fall die Unterschiede zwischen arm und reich noch größer machen,
ein armer Impfgeber lässt sich halt einfach impfen, ja das ist ja gerade der Punkt, der
arme Impfgegner hat dann quasi keine andere Möglichkeit wohingegen der reiche das kann,
das sage ich dir, das wäre ja eigentlich eine Ungleichbehandlung, letztendlich mich
persönlich juckt die ganze Geschichte eh nicht, ich bin nächste Woche geimpft und ich muss
auch ehrlich sagen, ich habe mich nicht irgendwie impfen lassen für die Allgemeinheit, sondern
dass ich den Scheiß nicht kriege, das ist tatsächlich ein schwieriges Thema.
Ja gut stimmt, das kommt ja auch noch dabei, jetzt wenn ich mir so recht überlege, das
kommt ja auch noch dabei, wenn du dich impfen lässt, dann schützt dich das ja hauptsächlich
davor, dass du keinen schweren Corona Verlauf bekommst und das würde ja heißen, wenn ich
mich impfen lasse für die Allgemeinheit, dann hat das doch überhaupt keine Auswirkungen,
oder?
Weil ich kann ja trotzdem weiterhin alle anstecken, oder sehe ich das jetzt falsch?
Also eigentlich das einzige wozu man sich impfen lassen, das einzige was man sich impfen
lassen sollte ist, dass man selbst nicht stirbt, das ist jetzt mal aus dem Punkt zu bringen,
also wirklich der größte und eigentlich fast der einzige Sinn von impfen ist, dass man
selbst nicht stirbt, was ja auch gut ist, das ist ja auch der Grund warum ich mich habe impfen
lassen.
Zumindest das ist echt ein interessantes Thema, ja auf jeden Fall ist das günstiger, wobei
ich halt nicht genau verstehe, was man damit bezwecken will, wenn ich mir jetzt so genau
überlege, also wenn du sagst, ok die Gefahr ist noch da und du willst das frühzeitig
erkennen, weil ja Gefahr ausgeht von Leuten die krank sind, dann müsstest du den Leuten
eigentlich Test bezahlen, weil sonst lassen die sich nicht testen und wenn es die Gefahr
nicht mehr gibt, dann müsstest du eigentlich sagen, ab jetzt machen wir gar nichts mehr,
was aber auch nicht so der Weisheitsletzter Schluss ist, es ist tatsächlich ein komplizierteres
Thema als ich mir das jetzt so vorgestellt habe vorher, warum sieht mein Abteil so aus,
wahrscheinlich weil das Java Script auf deiner Seite buggt, das ist übrigens auch die Frage
ob das zulässig ist, da weiß ich nicht wie die das machen wollen, da müsste dich ja
quasi der Veranstalter ausschließen, weil ansonsten wäre es ja quasi eine Pflicht,
anders kann man es ja nicht nennen, der Veranstalter kann dich ausschließen, aber das wird der
Veranstalter ja nicht machen, weil der Veranstalter wieder Geld haben.
Ja also es ist tatsächlich gar nicht so einfach und was ich gelesen habe ist ja, dass der
Test für Kinder und Risikogruppen oder Schwangere, Risikogruppen, Schwangere und Kinder, der
bleibt ja weiterhin kostenlos, naja mal gucken, mal gucken, bin echt gespannt, bin echt gespannt
was da rauskommt.
Bio und ich heute zweite Impfung, Druck im Arm war schneller da, jetzt etwas müde aber
sonst top.
Doch nice, ich hoffe Viper will nächste Woche genauso sein, ja das finde ich, ok das schießt
dann finde ich schon übers Ziel raus, ich verstehe es, ich verstehe es vielleicht für
sagen wir mal Leute die im Altenheim arbeiten oder sowas, selbst da kann man darüber diskutieren,
aber da kann ich das noch nachvollziehen, aber wie willst du das begründen, dass du
wenn du keine Ahnung, Frankfurt bei der Frankfurter Straßenreinigung bist oder so, dass die dich
rausschmeißen wenn dich nicht impfen lässt, außerdem das ist mir dann wirklich, also
ich bin dafür dass die Leute sich impfen lassen und ich bin es auch nicht verkehrt
dass man Anreize setzt, dass das passiert, wobei ich ja der Meinung bin eigentlich sollte,
warum ist es eigentlich, das muss mir jetzt mal einer erklären, warum ist es eigentlich
nicht Anreiz genug, dass man nicht stirbt wenn man sich infiziert, warum reicht das eigentlich
nicht, das habe ich, das verstehe ich nicht, das ist ja auch der Grund warum ich mich
haben impfen lassen, ja stimmt, stimmt, weil 5G Corona, dein Kind darf auch nur zum Kindergarten
wenn es gegen Masern geimpft ist, ja das stimmt, wobei Masern, ich weiß nicht ob Masern der
beste Vergleich ist, ich bin jetzt, ich bin weit davon entfernt irgendwie medizinisch
mich auszukennen, aber ich glaube gerade Masern ist ja schon eine Geschichte die auch gerade
bei Kindern, also sehr hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit hat auf gravierende Verläufe und Komplikationen,
wahrscheinlich deutlich höher als Corona und es ist auch ein guter Punkt chat, Maserninfo
gibt es schon lange, ja das wäre auch ein Punkt, ich bin ja dafür bei solchen Themen
sich prinzipiell das Für und Wider von beiden Seiten anzuhören, anstatt dieses Köppe eingeschlagen
auf Blitter und dann kann jeder für sich entscheiden, was er daraus für Konsequenzen
für sich zieht, ja das kann durchaus sein, ich hoffe nicht, ich hoffe nicht, was, Kupa
schreibt Leute Corona ist doch schon Schnee von gestern, das Marburger Fieber ist neu,
was für ein Ding, es ist Wahlkampf, da sind beide Seiten nicht rein, Moment mir gehts
nicht um Politiker, mir gehts um Leute wie du und ich und das sollten finde ich mehr
Leute machen, sich mal angucken, ok was sagt die eine Seite, was sagen die anderen Seiten,
und sich dann mal da selbst was in den Schluss daraus ziehen, anstatt einfach zu sagen jawoll,
was der sagt ist immer richtig und was der sagt ist immer falsch, da verzichtet man
auf viel Blödsinn, ich hab letztens in ein Interview geguckt, wo ich mich erinnere, mit
einem Flat Earth Typ, der war so krass davon überzeugt, es ist echter Wahnsinn, hat auch
erzählt es gibt einen Eiswall um die komplette Welt und da darf niemand hinfahren außer besonders
reiche VIPs, ok, wie auch immer man auf sowas kommt, ich weiß nicht, hat einen Link für
die Grafikkartenpreise, du kannst bei mir auf meiner Seite gucken, oh die ist kaputt,
ist die kaputt, oh ich glaub da ist ein Crawler abgekackt, da findest du aktuelle Grafikkartenpreise,
wie gesagt ich glaub das kann man nicht wirklich so vergleichen, da muss ich mir einfach mal
Gedanken drüber machen, also ich find das prinzipiell immer schlecht, wenn man Leute
zu irgendwas zwingt, ich bin der Meinung, die Leute müssen sich selbst Gedanken machen
und zu ihrer eigenen Überzeugung kommen, dass das sinnvoll ist, man kann nicht immer
bei allem was verbieten und die Leute zwingen, ok allem nehme ich zurück, allem ist vielleicht
ein bisschen übertrieben, aber da besteht schon die letzten Jahre die Tendenz zu, es
gibt sicherlich die ein oder anderen Sachen, da ist das sinnvoll, ja es ist zum Beispiel
durchaus sinnvoll, dass es verboten ist, dass man sich gegenseitig nicht den Kopf einschlagen
darf auf offener Straße, aber es gibt ja noch einen Mittelweg zwischen alles verboten und
alles erlaubt, also ich finde man sollte immer gucken, dass man für möglichst viele gangbare
Wege findet, anstatt gleich zu schreien, ah das müssen wir verbieten, das muss weg,
man muss die Leute zu zwingen, also ich finde es sinnvoll, dass die Leute sich impfen lassen,
keine Frage, deswegen mach ich das ja auch, aber ich bin immer, also erstmal pauschal
dagegen, es sei denn es überzeugt mich einer vom Gegenteil, dass es eine gute Idee ist,
die Leute zu ihrem Glück zu zwingen, ich mein Leute können auch freiwillig sich die
Leber kaputt saufen und Zigaretten den ganzen Tag, also man kann ja keinen zu seinem Glück
zwingen, wenn sie das nicht wollen, dann wollen sie es halt nicht, das einzige was man machen
kann ist, man muss die Leute halt überzeugen, sei es durch erklären, sei es durch Anreize,
was weiß ich, ganze Bratwurst gewinnen, habe ich jetzt schon gelesen, und ja es gibt bestimmt
Situationen wo man Sachen verbieten und erzwingen muss, aber das sollte nicht die Standardreaktion
sein auf irgendwas was einem nicht gefällt, hier guck mal, wenn ich auf die Straße gehe,
so ziemlich alle anderen Leute durch die pure Präsenz anderer Menschen fucken mich übelst
ab, ich sag doch jetzt aber auch nicht, ich will allen anderen Leuten verbieten auf die
Straße zu gehen, das wäre das Naheliegendste ja, aber wenn man mal ein bisschen in sich
geht komme ich auch relativ schnell auf die Idee, ja natürlich fände ich das cool, aber
an sich ist es eine bescheuerte Idee, obwohl ich da jetzt wenn ich mal genauer drüber
nachdenke eigentlich kein Problem hätte mit, die sollen einfach, die können alle rausgehen
wenn ich wieder drinnen bin, ich bin eh lange drin, dank Homeoffice noch mehr, Anschnallpflicht
ist so ein Ding wo ich es mir gefallen lasse, wobei es damals garantiert, das habe ich aber
nicht mitbekommen, da gab es damals auch sicherlich große Diskussionen zu, ne gut die Risikogruppen
die sind ja zum größten Teil schon geimpft, also ich sehe das ist ein schwieriges Thema
als ich mir das gedacht habe, Rauchverbot ist auch top, ne das sehe ich nicht so, ich finde
es gut wenn man nicht im Zug rauchen darf, ich finde es auch gut wenn man nicht im Büro
rauchen darf, aber den Leuten prinzipiell zu verbieten zu rauchen finde ich nicht gut,
wer sich die Lunge kaputt rauchen will darf das gerne machen, habe ich überhaupt keine
Schmerzen mit, der soll das so machen, dass es keine Auswirkungen auf andere Leute hat,
aber wenn der gerne sich seine Lunge kaputt rauchen will, dann soll der das machen, das
ist doch nicht mein Problem, also ich finde nicht sterben ist eigentlich ein guter Anreiz
für Corona Impfungen, kann ja sein, kann ja sein, gut da weiß ich wirklich nicht wie
es aktuell aussieht, ich habe vor ein paar Wochen mal eine Statistik gesehen, dass es
in den Krankenhäusern eigentlich ganz ok aussieht und nachdem wir es ja auch geschafft
haben in den letzten, wieviel Lockdowns hatten wir jetzt eigentlich drei oder so, die Krankenhäuser
nicht zu überlasten ist die Chance, dass wir jetzt mit 65 und wenn man die Kinder mal
mitzählt, das ist ja glaube ich über 70% oder so, Geimpfte die Krankenhäuser auch
nicht überlasten doch nicht schlechter als vorher oder, du steckst als Infizierter wesentlich
weniger Leute an, meinst du wenn ich geimpft bin, ja das ist ja auch nochmal ein Pluspunkt,
wobei ich mich halt hauptsächlich habe impfen lassen, weil ich selbst nicht sterben will.
Ja das frage ich mich auch, aber es gibt genug andere Dinge, es gibt genug andere Sachen,
wo du dich auch drüber aufregen kannst, das ist gar kein Problem.
Das ist eine gute Frage, ob der auch betroffen ist, wie will man das eigentlich machen, ich
überlege mir das gerade, wie will man das machen, also wenn man sagt die Leute sollen
den Test selbst bezahlen, aber zum Beispiel beim Hausarzt der Test ist nicht betroffen,
für Kinder ist nicht betroffen, für Risikopersonen und für Schwangere ist nicht betroffen, wer
will das eigentlich bewerten, das ist ja ein riesen BWL Stonks Management Aufwand, das zu
zuteilen, wobei eigentlich nicht, vielleicht gehst du einfach zu einem Testzentrum, zeigst
dass du Risikopatient bist und dann musst du was bezahlen, ansonsten nicht, ne wahrscheinlich
lässt sich das doch relativ einfach händeln, ja bin mal gespannt.
Max heute zweimal geleakt ja in der Gabel, in der Gabel habe ich mich geleakt, in der
Gabel und im Wasserhahn.
Ja wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, das ist ja das was ich vorhin gemeint habe, dann wäre
es ja wirklich so eine Art Impfpflicht, ich mein man kann natürlich sagen, keine Ahnung
ob das wirklich so ist, aber gehen wir mal aus, wenn das so wäre, dann ist es ja so,
dass man zwar sagt nein es wäre keine Testpflicht, nein es wäre keine Testpflicht, aber wenn
du dein normales Leben nicht mehr leben kannst, ohne dich testen zu lassen, oder impfen zu
lassen, dann wäre es ja doch eine versteckte Pflicht, wisst ihr wie ich mein, und gerade
wenn du dann auch noch Veranstaltern vorschreiben willst, wie sie ihre Veranstaltung zu gestalten
haben, dann könnten sie auch gleich reinschreiben du musst, wenn du eh keine Chance hast dran
vorbeizukommen, also wenn das wirklich so ist, dann sieht das für mich eher so aus,
als möchte man eigentlich, dass es eine Pflicht gibt, aber versteck die ein bisschen besser,
dass man quasi nicht gesagt bekommen kann, ihr wollt die Leute verpflichten.
Max League, ja ich seh tatsächlich Dance Gaming relativ, also wenn das so ist, ja, wobei
ich mich da auch frage, wie das funktionieren soll, weil prinzipiell, es sei denn es gibt
entgegengesetzte Regelungen, prinzipiell hast du erstmal Vertragsfreiheit zwischen Veranstalter
und die Leute, die hingehen, also wenn die Veranstalter sagen, das ist okay, dann müsste
das eigentlich auch gehen, es sei denn es gibt halt irgendwelche Regeln, die das verbieten,
dass das Veranstalter sagen, wobei ich mir halt auch wieder vorstelle, die Veranstalter
wollen das von sich aus ja gar nicht, die Veranstalter wollen ja, dass möglichst viele
Leute kommen, dass sie ihren Scheiß verkaufen können, also was für einen Anreiz sollte
ein Restaurant oder ein Veranstalter haben, zu sagen zum Beispiel, ich lass nur Geimpfte
rein und gehen wir wirklich von aus, es fehlen noch 30%, da würden die sich ja auf einen
Schlag 30% potenzieller Restaurantgänger wegnehmen, aber deswegen beschäftige ich mich
auch nicht weiter mit dem Thema, weil mir das Thema auf den Sack geht mittlerweile,
jetzt hab ich auch keinen Bock mehr dazu was zu sagen, für mich ist das eh erledigt, ich
bin nächste Woche doppelt geimpft und gut ist, dann ist mir das alles egal, dann sterbe
ich nicht mal an Corona, meine Mutter auch nicht und dann ist es gut, Rest juckt mich
nicht, zu was war das, ach du meinst, dass die Leute gekündigt werden sollten, ja das
finde ich auch bescheuert, so jetzt mal in China Kinesen einkaufen, ja, der Chat sollte
die Keg W-Partei gründen, ne ich bin eher für Keg hier um, China ich find schon mal
gut, dass du Dance-Gaming-Sub bist, der einzige Let's-Player, den ich mir angucken kann,
hatte
Das ist halt die Frage, ob das anderen schadet, das ist halt, ich will jetzt nicht, das ist
halt die Frage, wo ich mir auch gerade Gedanken drüber gemacht hab.
Wenn du weiterhin wirklich Leute ansteckst, trotz geimpft, ist ja, eigentlich schützt
du ja damit dann keine Ungeimpften, die Ungeimpften untereinander gefährden sich, die sind dann
ungeimpft, sind selber daran schuld, ich selbst kann es nicht bekommen und wenn ein Ungeimpfter
von einem Ungeimpften angesteckt wird, ja dann muss ich ja eh keiner beschweren, oder?
Die hätten sich auch impfen lassen können.
Oder nicht?
Ja doch, Moment, Moment, nee so einfach ist es nicht, es gibt ja immer noch Leute, die
sich nicht impfen lassen können, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, ja Thema Change, genau,
ok weiter, jetzt kaufen wir einen, so Chat, Bam, also ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt,
ich habe jetzt einfach nur random ein bisschen gelabert, ihr wisst, ohne dass ich große Ahnung
von dem Thema hab, nur das erste, was mir eingefallen ist, also es sollte, ich sag
jetzt hier an der Stelle, es sollte keiner über irgendwas entscheiden für sein Leben,
nur weil ich was gesagt hab im Stream.
Ja gut, aber es ging ja gerade darum, wenn Ungeimpfte, Ungeimpfte anstecken, da dürfte
ja im größten Fall der Fälle die Leute nur wirklich mal selber daran schuld sein, nein
und das nicht als nächstes Thema und auch C++ nicht als nächstes Thema, C++ hab ich
mich gestern schon lange noch darüber aufgeregt, so also wir machen jetzt mal weiter, was ich
euch gestern noch zeigen wollte ist folgendes, ihr wisst, ich hab ja einige Sachen von Shelly
bei mir am Start, zum Beispiel Shelly 1 Relays, Assembly als nächstes Thema, hm, das wäre
tatsächlich mal ein gutes Thema, wir haben ja schon mal ein paar Mal Assembler programmiert,
so light für den, wir haben einmal so ganz light mit 10 Makros und einmal den ultra low
power Prozessor vom ESP32 mit, ich glaub der hat 8 Assembler Befehle, der ist relativ easy,
mach mal Gita Stream Reverse Engineering, ne da bin ich zu lowbrane für, ich hab das Programm
schon ein paar Mal versucht zu verwenden, ich hab's nie gecheckt,
zu low IQ für, mach mal was mit Java, wenn schon willst du was mit Kotlin machen, die
Probeklausur, oh ne das krieg ich jetzt nicht hin, also genau, wie gesagt, hab ich euch
ja ein paar Mal gezeigt, ich hab unter anderem bei mir paar Shelly Relays am Start, das coole
an den Dingern ist halt, dass man die in die Steckdose einbauen kann, also in den Schalter,
in der Wand, weil die so klein sind und da kann man dann beispielsweise sein Licht an
der Decke drüber schalten und es weiterhin mit dem Schalter schalten, das ist ja eines
der Probleme, die man hat, wenn man anfängt sein Home, sein Haus auszustatten mit irgendwelchen
smarten RGB Klübinnen und sowas, dann hast du nämlich das Problem, dass du das wunderbar
über eine App oder über ein Webinterface oder sonst was steuern kannst, aber wenn du
den Schalter drückst, ist die Klübne aus und wenn die Klübne aus ist, dann kann das
Smart Home sie nicht mehr steuern, so und das verhinderst du damit, weil du baust dir
ein Relay ein und das Relay schaltet die Klübne, das Relay kann geschaltet werden über WLAN
und das Relay kann geschaltet werden über den alten Schalter an der gleichen Stelle,
damit hast du auch nicht das Problem, wenn keine Ahnung, die Frau, die Mutter, wer auch
immer, ich sag mal technisch nicht so versierte BenutzerInnen sagen, dass Schalter das einzig
wahre ist, dann kannst du sagen, es gibt weiterhin einen Schalter und trotzdem ist die Klübne
smart, wie teuer das ist, die Shelley sind tatsächlich relativ günstig, die 1er, die
gehen los ab 9 Euro, aber das kostet noch, kommt noch ein bisschen Steuer drauf, aber
das ist echt in Ordnung, also du kannst den 4er Pack für 35 Euro holen, aber brauchst
du dafür eine spezielle Leitung, also es gibt eigentlich für fast alles mittlerweile
eine Lösung, du hast den Shelley 1L, der braucht, jetzt müssen wir mal die Elektriker,
die Elektrikstellzer hier helfen, der braucht neutral, live, nee was ist L, keine Ahnung,
zumindest gibt es auch den 1L, der braucht weniger, was war denn der Unterschied nochmal,
genau, das geht auch, wenn es keinen neutralen Leiter gibt, so und damit kann man dann so
Dinger hier zum Beispiel machen, guck, du schließt den Schalter an, du schließt dann,
nein warte mal, warte mal, lass mal überlegen, wie war das nochmal, warte mal, wie war das
nochmal, Switch 1, Switch X, ich hab keinen 1L, das ist keine Erdung, Schutzleiter ist
da 2 farbiger, das stimmt doch aber so nicht, das muss doch auch irgendwie, ok, auf dem
Bild fehlt der blaue, genau, aber den blauen brauche ich hierfür nicht, kann mir mal einer
als Electro Noob erklären, warum ich überhaupt 3 brauche, ich kenne das nur von Schaltungen
und da brauche ich immer nur plus und minus, Rest ist vollkommen egal, also oder halt mein
entwegen halt 3,3 Volt, 5 Volt und Ground, warum brauche ich denn dann 3, Phase ist Zuleiter
und neutral Leiter ist Rückleiter, ja aber dann sollte doch hier eigentlich das blaue
dran und nicht das oder, weil wie fließt denn der Strom hier zurück, Bub S, oder ich
den Kram nicht selbst eingebaut habe, da hätte ich ja voll verkackt, tja, die haben noch
Installationsbilder hier irgendwie, how to pay, wir gucken uns jetzt mal so ein Installationsbild
von an, wartet mal, bevor ich dir so irgendeinen Mist empfehle, Strom Staff ist mir echt zu
wild, ja mir auch, deswegen mache ich das nicht selbst, wobei die hier gehen, hier kannst
ihr einfach für den ersten Stock die Sicherung ausschalten, also ich habe das da, also ich
habe das meistens zum Glück nicht selbst gemacht, wäre schlecht ausgegangen, aber ich
habe es einmal mit einem YouTube Video hinbekommen, allerdings nicht den 1L, sondern den normalen,
die haben doch da irgendwo, die haben doch da so ein Installations, hier Wiring Diagrams,
also, how to connect, ja siehste, warum geht denn N an O und nicht an, ah Moment, Moment,
ist das so, ist das so, ich mache N normalerweise an N und dann den rotbraunen, rotgrünen an
O, ne, O ist doch das was schaltet oder, ist O nicht das wo dann eigentlich die Lampe dran
ist, Bob S, ja was denn, doch na klar ist es da wo die Lampe dran ist, wo soll die Lampe
denn sonst dran, guck mal hier, das Bild ist aber auch kacke, na das hier ist der Switch,
doch das ist der Switch an der Wand, ok wir kriegen bessere Bilder, ok exellent, exellent
Bilder hier, genau, du drückst den Schalter und dann, ich sag doch hier kommt die Lampe
dran, ist doch richtig was ich gesagt hab, ok jetzt hört es bei mir auf, O ist Output,
wie gibt das Bild Sinn, O ist auch L Output, ja, ja da kommt die Lampe dran, ah, warte mal
ich glaube jetzt hab ich es gecheckt, das heißt der Strom geht hier durch, ah hier,
ok jetzt hab ich es gecheckt, der Strom geht hier durch, hier dazwischen ist eigentlich
der Schalter im Shelly drinnen und dann drücke ich den Knopf oder dann schalte ich den Schalter,
dann schalte das Relay hier das durch, dann geht das hier durch in die Lampe und hier
fließt das wieder zurück, oder, ja gut egal, wie auch immer, da wollte ich eigentlich
überhaupt nicht drauf raus, ich hab mich jetzt leider ein bisschen sidetracken lassen
wieder, was ich euch eigentlich zeigen wollte ist, die haben was neues und das hab ich mir
überlegt ob ich das, das mach ich nicht selbst, ihr habt ja gesehen wie wahnsinnig viel Ahnung
ich von so klassische Elektrosachen hab, das mach ich dann nicht selbst, ich sag's euch
gleich, ich lass das immer mein Elektriker machen und ich hab mir überlegt ob ich mir
so ein Teil hole, das ist jetzt neu, also da geh ich garantiert nicht dran, das sag ich
euch komplett, da bringt mir auch die Corona Impfung nichts dagegen, so und das ist jetzt
neu, das haben die glaub ich erst vor 2-3 Monaten rausgebracht und damit, die haben
leider kein gescheites Bild auch vom Webinterface und so was, damit kannst du den Verbrauch messen
komplett im ganzen Haus und du hast noch quasi so 3, wie nennt man das, diese Klemmen, wo
du dann sogar noch unterschiedliche, Unterschiede machen kannst zwischen Erdgeschoss und ersten
Stock und so was, Induktivmessklemmen, ja genau, klingt gut, ja und ich bin ja die ganze
Zeit schon dran, dass ich irgendwie mein Stromzählergescheit ausgelesen bekomme, ich probier's jetzt
mit einer ESP32CAM, weil das andere was ich da gestrickt hab nicht allzu gut funktioniert
und sowas, so ne Lösung die schon fix und fertig ist, die sogar noch so ne, so ne Dienleisten,
wie nennt man das, Hut Schiene, Hut Schienenklemmen Ding hat, das fänd ich echt cool, ich hab
mir überlegt, ob ich mir das net mal bestellen soll und einfach auf weitere Versuche verzichte
und meinem Elektriker sage, bauma plitz ein, eine Spende auf Besos, nice Spende, hutsch
dankeschön, für den Sub, weil ich muss mal gucken, ich hab bestimmt irgendwas vergessen
heute, Tomtricks hat auch Subscribed hier, hier schön, Besos ist outdated, stimmt, der
macht das gar nicht mehr, ich hab bis heute auch noch nicht verstanden, warum an modernen
Zählern keine Schrittstelle dran ist, ist oftmals, mein Zähler ist aber nicht neu,
ich hab nen Zähler oben für den ersten Stock, der hat so nen Impuls LED dran, das ist total
einfach auszulesen, hab ich schon mit Microcontroller gemacht, das ist wirklich easy, funktioniert
auch, fürs gesamte Haus hab ich halt noch so nen alten Ferrari Zähler, sowas mit Scheibe,
so das richtige Boomer Ding, ja, das ist älter als mein Opa wahrscheinlich da, das ist wahrscheinlich
200 Jahre alt oder so, keine Ahnung, so und da hab ich jetzt schon ein paar Versuche gemacht,
die letzte Versuche war, da läuft ja immer so ein rotes Feld hier unten durch, es steht
neben drauf wie viel Umdrehung gleich wie viel Kilowattstunden und es läuft dann immer
so ein rotes Ding, so ein rotes Ding durch, wenn das einmal tickt quasi, so und ich hab
mir quasi sowas hier in der Richtung gebaut, sowas hier in der Richtung gebaut, nur selbst,
mit nem Infrarotsensor, der erkennt, wenn diese rote Scheibe durchläuft, die Sache ist nur
die, dass das zwar funktioniert, aber das erkennt manchmal Ticks, wo keine sind und
manchmal erkennt es Ticks auch nicht, das ist nicht so wahnsinnig zuverlässig und ich
hab das schon debounced, also ich sag schon, hey, also extrem debounced, ich sag schon,
wenn es mal, wenn es 500 Millisekunden lang nichts mehr kommt, erst dann gilt der Wert
und sowas, also mehr Logik kann ich da nicht mehr drum herum stricken, deswegen ist jetzt
mein nächster Versuch, ich versuche das mit einer ESP-CAM einfach hier per Bilderkennung
auszulesen, das wäre ja auch noch ne Möglichkeit.
Festfehler gleichen sich aus, ne, die stimmen leider nicht, also ich hab mal den, den richtigen
Hardcore-Test dafür gemacht, für meine Zählerkonstruktion und da hab ich, was hab ich denn alles eingeschaltet,
warm Wasser, Heizlüfter oben, Heizlüfter unten, den Herd, Wasserkocher, ich glaub,
das wars, also volle Pulle, also normalerweise läuft der Stromzähler richtig Pepega Style,
Millimeter für Millimeter quasi und da ging der auf einmal richtig steil, blub, blub,
blub, blub, das waren ja auch, keine Ahnung, äh, was war das denn, das waren ja allein
schon, was weiß ich, 2000 Watt oder so für den Heizlüfter, doppelt, oben und unten,
was braucht so nen, was braucht so nen Herd, mit, mit zwei, zwei, so nen Ceran Kochfeld
Herd mit, mit, mit zwei Platten an, wahrscheinlich nochmal 2000 oder so, Wasserkocher nochmal
2000, also keine Ahnung, ich hab da mit dem Testing, fragt mich nicht, 10.000 Watt verballert
oder so und da ging der, ging da schon ordentlich ab, die haben wahrscheinlich gedacht, ich
hab meine Bitcoin Farmer, Farm, angeschaltet, richtig, deswegen hab ich mir auch gedacht,
äh, deswegen hab ich mir auch gedacht, ich lass einfach, ich kauf mir so nen Shelly Ding
und lass es meinen Elektriker einbauen und dann hab ich eigentlich nie wieder Probleme,
nein, ich kann auch, wenn die den, wenn die den Zähler wirklich mal wechseln, sollte
da wirklich mal die Stadtwerke echt mal auf die Idee kommen, äh, das zu tauschen, dann
kann ich das mit dem Shelly weiter auslesen, ne, ne, ne, ne, das glaub ich nicht, ich,
ich würde mal fast sagen, diese Dinger sind sogar, äh, die sind bombensicher quasi, also
das Haus kann einstürzen und der Zähler zählt immer noch, würde ich jetzt einfach mal von
ausgehen, also das ist so ein Teil, das werd ich mir wahrscheinlich mal bestellen, Shop
Now, wobei 82 Euro net net ohne sind, aber ich mein, wie war das Jugendwort des Jahres
aus dem Weg Geringverdiener, wir adden das jetzt einfach mal, weil ich finde, es ist
ne coole Geschichte, weil man sieht, was man verbraucht und am besten auch noch in Zusammenhang
mit, wo das verbraucht wird, also dass ich sehe, ob das quasi Gesamt ist, Erdgeschoss
oder, na gut, Erdgeschoss ergibt sich, Erdgeschoss ist Gesamtverbrauch minus, minus, äh, erster
Stock, na wobei, das stimmt nicht, Gesamtverbrauch minus erster Stock, minus Garten, minus Terrasse,
minus eventuell in Zukunft tatsächlich mal Elektroauto, na so ganz so genau ist das dann
doch nicht, ich habe gerade herausgefunden, wer das Jugendwort akkurat mit eingeschleust
hat, aha, und wer war es, Jugendwort des Jahres komplett Lost, Lost ist dieses Jahr
nicht dabei, also ich persönlich bin ja für Cringe und das andere hab ich schon wieder
vergessen, was war das, Cringe und Wild, Cringe und Wild, hätte ich ja gesagt, Sus war auch
dabei, aber ich, ich bin für, ja also, wenn ich mir was aussuchen dürfte, dann wärs
natürlich Poggers oder Pains Champ, aber sowas, sowas gibt's ja, gibt's ja da nicht,
da ist Twitch immer noch zu Niche für, was so ein Comedy-Tiktoker, wer sonst, okay, Comedy-Tiktoker,
ich muss sagen, ich konsumiere äußerst wenig TikTok, aber ich muss echt sagen, es gibt
schon ein paar wirklich lustige Sachen, es gibt aber auch unglaublich vieles, Moment,
ich muss das passende Emote raussuchen, es gibt auch unglaublich viel dummes Zeug und
ich würd sogar soweit sagen, da reicht noch nicht mal 3-Head für aus, da bist du schon
2-Head, also für manches TikTok-Zeug, es sind aber auch ein paar echt lustige Sachen
dabei, 0,5-Head, ja, 0-Head, so, also das wollt ich euch mal zeigen, ich glaube, gesagt,
den wär ich mir mal ordern und dann mal von meinem Elektriker einbauen, also Leute, macht
euch keine Gedanken, ich bastel nicht selbst an dem Kram rum, ich lass das mein Elektriker
machen, außer einmal, da hab ich aber, ich hab Sicherungen rausgemacht und ich hab das
nach ganz streng, na, also so einen Shelly ganz streng nach einem YouTube-Video eingebaut
und das hat funktioniert, aber vielleicht sollte ich das lieber wieder raus machen,
wer weiß nicht, dass die Bude demnächst noch abfackelt, ne, ne, macht euch keine Gedanken,
wie gesagt, ich hab das alles bisher, bis auf das eine, mein Elektriker einbauen lassen,
aber ich hab ihn bei dem anderen auch mal schauen lassen, das scheint wohl okay zu sein, das
leuchtet ja wie im Club, ja, oh, das ist so cringe, das Telekom-Video gewesen, das Fleer-Case
ist gut, ja, ja, das Fleer-Case ist wirklich gut, das haben wir hier sogar im Stream schon
mal ausprobiert, das hier, äh, das da, das ist wirklich gut, es ist anscheinend sogar
lieferbar, ja dann, auf gehts, also ich muss ehrlich sagen, für mich das beste Gehäuse,
für den Raspberry Pi 4, ich mein, leider bezahlt man für das Gehäuse quasi die Hälfte vom
Raspberry Pi, aber gut, der Vierer mit mehr Rahmen, ein Drittel, ein Drittel noch mal
extra drauf, das ist aber gut, ähm, weil du brauchst keinen Lüfter, Lüfter auf den
Raspberry Pi finde ich immer persönlich ein bisschen pains-champ, das gute daran ist,
das gesamte Gehäuse ist glaub aus Aluminium, das heißt du leitest die Abwärme von deinem
Chip erstmal über das gesamte Gehäuse ab und wenn es dann irgendwo noch halbwegs im
Freien steht, dann wird das auch nicht zu warm und du hast ja auch deinen Raspberry
Pi selber seltenst, 24-7 unter Volllast, China heißt das nicht China, du kannst beides sagen,
deswegen, wir sind ja hier, wir sind hier wahnsinnig inclusive, deswegen sag ich auch
immer chinesische Chinaschinesen, dass da alle sich angesprochen fühlen.
Also das ist ein gutes Gehäuse, kann ich dir nur empfehlen.
Ja ich mein guck mal, wir haben Emotes für Kokomrits, wir haben Emotes für Kokonas,
wir haben Emotes für dicke Leute, wir haben Emotes für Franzosen, wir haben Emotes für
dumme Leute, wir haben Emotes für schlaue Leute, wir haben Emotes für Leute mit Durchfall,
wir haben Emotes für Leute die schwitzen, für Windows User, für Stadia User, für
Verschwörungstheorie Leute, für Leute mit Geburtstag, KappaPride, wir haben alles, wir
haben alles hier, alles was man so braucht, heute in der Teamrunde war lustig, mein Chef
hat gemeint, hallo liebe Administratorin oder irgendwie sowas, so aus Spaß, hat er gemeint
leider, muss ich das so sagen, er sucht, also er hat ja bis jetzt keine Administratorin
gefunden, obwohl er, obwohl er in der Stellenanzeige immer MWD sucht oder Malta Felix, Malta Felix
mit in der Teamrunde, also der Max hat mir letztens erzählt was MWD heißt, das heißt
männlich-weiß-deutsch, darfst du nicht so laut sagen, im Zweifelsfall kriegt so einer
einen falschen Hals, der hat mich geaudet, ja ist doch egal, also die sind da zum größten
Teil nicht so 3-Head im Kopf, dass sie das ernst nehmen würden, ich sag das 4-Case ist
gut, hab ich eben bestellt, ja das wird dir gefallen, das ist nice, dann gibt es leider
die Leute die das ernst nehmen, so dummes Gelaber, ja leider, das stimmt, da muss man
gerade auf Twitch, da muss man mittlerweile echt aufpassen, ich mein daran wird sich jetzt
ja wirklich noch keiner stören, ist ja eindeutig auch als Gag erkennbar, aber auf Twitch musste
man mittlerweile echt aufpassen, habt ihr mitbekommen, wo wir gerade bei diesem Thema sind, ich will
da nicht zu lange drauf rumbreiten auf diesem Thema, habt ihr mitbekommen das Amazon jetzt
ein Diversity Programm hat für ihre Filmproduktion und das in diesem Programm zum Beispiel unter
anderem drin steht, was für mich komplett unverständlich ist, dass man darauf achten
soll, wenn Minderheiten dargestellt werden, dass man bei der Auswahl der Schauspieler darauf
geachtet wird, dass die Schauspieler auch diese Gruppen repräsentieren, also sprich wenn
ich jetzt einen Schwulen in meinem Film haben will, dann soll ich darauf achten, dass es
auch in echt ein schwuler Schauspieler ist, aber da stellt man doch komplett in Frage,
warum überhaupt noch Schauspieler, ist nicht der Sinn von einem Schauspieler gerade, dass
der das spielt oder unter anderem das spielt, wo er nicht persönlich involviert ist, das
verstehe ich nicht, das leuchtet mir nicht ein, ich meine sollte das nicht eigentlich
gerade einen Schauspieler sogar wollen, dass er unterschiedlichste Sachen spielt, ja also
das fand ich doch schon ein bisschen befremdlich, ich bin mir eh nicht sicher, ob diese ganzen
krampfhaft forcierten Dinger wirklich für viel mehr Akzeptanz sorgen, da habe ich so
meine Zweifel, naja mal gucken wie sich das entwickelt, ja sowas in der Richtung, sowas
in der Richtung steht da drinnen, das ist total wir irgendwie, ja gut das verstehe ich,
das verstehe ich ja noch, das verstehe ich ja noch, zumal wir es ja in der heutigen Zeit
wirklich auch nicht mehr nötig haben weiße Schauspieler zu nehmen und schwarz anzumalen,
das verstehe ich ja noch, das hat ja auch wirklich rassistische Genere, das verstehe
ich ja noch, das ist ein Fall wo ich sagen kann ok der leuchtet mir ein, aber trotzdem
gerade Schauspieler sollten doch scharf drauf sein möglichst unterschiedliche vielfältige
Rollen zu spielen, ich meine die wollen ja auch zeigen was sie können, genau heute hast
du auch genug schwarz für die schwarze spielen können, das ist nicht das Problem, ich verstehe
das nicht, also diese Sache ja, aber diese ganzen anderen Regelungen, man muss sich auch
mal überlegen, wenn das wirklich so sein sollte, dass Amazon das möchte, dass quasi der persönliche
Lebensstil mit der gespielten Rolle übereinstimmt, das heißt doch im Endeffekt auch, dass sich
jeder jetzt als lesbisch schwul oder was auch immer outen muss damit er noch Rollen bekommt
oder, also das leuchtet mir überhaupt nicht ein, ich finde das ist genau das Gegenteil
von dem wie es eigentlich sein sollte, man versucht damit quasi übers Knie gebrochen
irgendwas zu forcieren wo man genau das Gegenteil von erreicht, verstehe nicht, aber ich muss
auch nicht alles verstehen, ja gut das stimmt, dass da oftmals nicht so mit Menschenverstand
herangegangen wird, das ist mir auch schon eingeleuchtet ja, ich finde es dürfen nur
deutsche in englischen filmen deutsche spielen, naja es durften ja schon genug deutsche in
englischen filmen deutsche spielen, naja gut wir machen jetzt weiter, habe ich heute
nur gelesen, habe ich mir gedacht ok, bewegt das nicht eigentlich genau das Gegenteil von
dem, was man so will, teile mal den link zu diesem angeblichen Ding, du meinst das von
amazon diversity richtlinien, ja das erster treffer hier zum beispiel, amazon studios führt
neue diversity richtlinien ein, so und das gibt es auch irgendwo als pdf wobei ich nicht
sagen muss, also nicht behaupten will, dass ich das komplette pdf gelesen hätte, ja also
ich habe mir das nicht ausgedacht, also das ist aktuell wohl wirklich ein ding und das
verstehe ich nicht, also ich habe den einen und man erreicht dadurch eher das gegenteil,
das ist übrigens auch ein punkt warum ich, um bogen zu schlagen zu dem was ich vorher
gesagt habe, warum ich es in der regel nicht sinnvoll finde pauschal bei allem zu sagen
man muss es irgendwie verbieten oder man muss das irgendwie die leute verpflichten oder
sonst wie klar es gibt extreme beispiele ist das notwendig, weil dadurch überzeugst du
ja keinen, die leute müssen die sachen aus innerem antrieb machen, dann ist das auch
was langfristiges und dann ändert sich auch mit der zeit was, wenn die leute das nicht
aus innerem antrieb machen sondern vielleicht aus angst weil sie nachteile in anderen bereichen
haben, dann kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass das zu langfristige ändert sich führt
wo die leute auch dann wirklich sagen ok da stehe ich dahinter, magst du erlebst noch
2 plus 2 grad, mache ich das, dann darf ich das aufmachen, noch mal glück gehabt, noch
mal glück gehabt hier, monarch s ja wunderbar, ich erlebe es noch, da bin ich ja ganz scharf
drauf, ok wenn du zwischen 20 und 29 jahre alt bist, ist es wahrscheinlich dass du eine
erderhitzung von 2,5 grad erlebst, ich bin zwischen 30 und 39, ok ich erlebe, na komm
wenn ich alt werde 2071, ok lass mal überlegen, ich bin sagen wir 2071 minus 1984, da bin
ich 87, ja komm, das ist durchaus im bereich des möglichen heute, ah 87, 87 fang ich und
jetzt habe ich zugemacht, wo war das jetzt, mit 87 easy, 2,5 grad, aber rente erleben
wir alle nicht, dass wir ordentlich rente kriegen erleben wir wahrscheinlich wirklich
nicht ja, die rente erlebe ich ziemlich sicher hoffe ich mal, also habe ich zumindest vor,
aber ich werde wahrscheinlich nichts mehr bekommen großartig, aber zum glück habe
ich die gesetzliche rente, die betriebsrente und wahrscheinlich bis dahin auch genug kohle
anarbeit ich, also ich mache mir da um meinen ruhe stand keine sorgen, ich habe eh nicht
vor bis 65 oder 67 zu arbeiten, also nicht so wie jetzt, da habe ich keinen bock drauf,
game up, dankeschön für den sub, 15 monat hypersubscription hier, da kommt der bwl max
raus, ne den bwl max gibt es nicht mehr, ihr wisst ja ich habe früher mal eine bwl ausbildung
gemacht, aber das gibt es nicht mehr, ich hasse bwl zeug mittlerweile, das liegt aber
hauptsächlich nicht, das liegt gar nicht so sehr an bwl, sondern es liegt an den meisten
leuten, die damit was zu tun haben, naja, so wir wollten eigentlich zeug einkaufen, ich
weiß ich lasse mich mit der ultra sidetrack, aber heute ist ausruhen und einkaufen, das
zähle ich jetzt mal unter einkaufen, wisst ihr was ich auch so ein bisschen bedenklich
finde, das muss ich jetzt einfach mal loswerden, ja, ich habe ja am anfang des streams, ich
habe ja am anfang des streams gesagt, ok gerade um das thema testpflicht, impfpflicht
habe ich mir noch nicht viele gedanken zugemacht, ich labere jetzt einfach mal frei drauf los,
das erste was mir so einfällt, wisst ihr was ich echt bedenklich finde in der aktuellen
zeit, dass ich mir wirklich gedanken machen müsste, dass ich, also ich müsste mir jetzt
eigentlich wirklich gedanken machen, lösche ich diesen stream und alle clips, weil, mach
ich nicht, kann ich euch gleich schon sagen, mach ich nicht, aber eigentlich müsste man,
müsste man sich da heutzutage wirklich schon gedanken drüber machen, lösche ich das,
nicht dass irgendjemand da reinguckt, irgendeine aussage nimmt, die vielleicht auch eventuell
mit oder ohne kontext nicht ganz dem aktuellen meinungsbild entspricht und dann gehts ab,
ey das ist kein witz, es gibt wirklich, ich hab das so oft schon gelesen auf leute, auf
twitter, die gesagt haben so nach dem motto, lasst uns mal rausfinden wer das ist, ja oder
so nach dem motto zerstört ihm, zerstört ihm irgendwie alles und sowas, total gestörte
leute alter am start, also ich finde niemand sollte dafür seinen job und seine existenz
verlieren, also gerade twitter ist da ganz schlimm, mail an deine sponsor draus ja, von
dem hab ich schonmal, von dem hab ich schonmal nen clip gesehen und dann muss ich sagen,
also ich hab vor jahren mal von ihm ein paar videos gesehen, da hat er noch irgendwelche
gaming sachen gemacht, da hab ich mir eigentlich nix bei gedacht und letztens hab ich irgendwie
nen clip von ihm gesehen und da hab ich mir gedacht, irgendwie, das ist quasi an negativer
sache, also diskussionskultur und passiver aggressivität seinen gesprächspartnern gegenüber
kaum noch zu überbieten, also das war wirklich echt heftig, bis er dann am ende sogar was
gesagt hat in der richtung, ich will ja hier nicht, dass einer noch denkt du hättest recht,
gtf, also warum lehnt man sich da leute überhaupt ein mit denen da drüber zu reden, ja man sollte
immer mal zumindest noch die option offen halten, dass teile der aussagen seines diskussionspartner
vielleicht nicht ganz bescheuert sind, reaction stream, stimmt, das 24 minuto ist zu lang
ansonsten will ich jetzt weder sonderlich positiv negativ sagen, ich hab mir außer
diese 2 sachen nichts anguckt, ich kenn es von früher und ich kenn jetzt diesen ausstieg,
den ich letztens mal auf youtube gesehen hab, wo ich mir gedacht hab, alter, sehr unangenehmer
zeitgenosse, ja und der chat war das allerschlimmste, genau, ich hab auf youtube nen ausschnitt gesehen,
da ging es um, weiß gar nicht, was war das, ich glaub das hat auch irgendwas mit corona,
nee doch, doch das hat irgendwas mit corona lock down oder so zu tun, weiß gar nicht mehr
was das war, das wurde mir empfohlen und da hab ich noch ein bisschen durchgeskippt, am
ende hat er wirklich gesagt zu seinem gesprächspartner, ich will ja sich zitieren, aber schon mehr
oder weniger wortwörtlich, ich will ja nicht, dass die leute denken hier du hättest recht
oder irgendwie sowas, ganz merkwürdig, und dabei war der chat, derzeit war der chat eingeplendet
und der chat, alter, das war der wahnsinn, das war wirklich an 3 hat time kaum zu überbieten,
also der chat war wirklich ein, soll ich das umschreiben, fällt mir gar nichts zu ein,
vielleicht, ja mein chat ist feifett, mein chat ist feifett, wir reden über gar keinen,
ich will eigentlich mich da gar nicht zu äußern, hab ich keinen bock drauf, die sollen alle
machen was sie wollen, so weiter im text, wir können uns das linus tech tips video heute
nicht angucken, es ist zu lang und ich muss jetzt mal kurz noch gucken, was ich noch holen
wollte, ich hab ja heute wieder nix geschafft, du late clip ship, macht was ihr wollt, macht
was ihr wollt, so, also, wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben, achja, genau, ich hab mir nämlich
tatsächlich noch was aufgeschrieben, was ich mir mit euch angucken wollte, nämlich was
ich mega nice finde, ihr wisst ja, ich hab nen roborock s5 als staubsauger robotter und
ich hab jetzt letztens gesehen, es gibt jetzt eine, für den roborock s7 gibt es jetzt eine
absaugstation, das haben die schon angekündigt vor einem halben jahr und sie haben gesagt,
ihr könnt den s7 ruhig kaufen, nein das ist keine absaugstation in dieser richtung, wobei
ich bin mir sicher, ich bin mir sicher, es sind sicherlich schon die ersten leute im
krankenhaus gewesen, weil sie da ihr ding reingesteckt haben, 100%ig, Leute wir kennen die menscheit,
wir kennen die menscheit und das erste was die leute machen wenn sie so ein ding haben
ist, da ihr ding reinstecken wahrscheinlich, also die leute, also manche, ja, das garantiert
schon leute im krankenhaus gewesen, weil sie sich ihr ding eingeklemmt haben in der roborock
saugstation.
So, und zumindest, show me hat gesagt, man kann sich den s7 kaufen, weil in zukunft kommt
eine saugstation raus, dass man keinen beutel mehr braucht bzw. nicht mehr ausleeren muss,
beutel in der station braucht man immer noch und die sind kompatibel, ich will jetzt einfach
mal sehen, wie kompatibel ist der kram, also haben die ihr versprechen da gehalten, das
müssen wir uns jetzt mal kurz zusammen angucken, sieben minuten halten, halten wir aus, hat
das doll wehgetan, also ich hab dann auch keine erfahrung gemacht, ich stelle es mir
auch äußerst schmerzhaft vor, wenn er da reingesaugt wird, noch nicht, wie ich eben
gesagt hab, man sollte nie sachen ausschließen, ja, es ist wie bei allem, es gibt ganz selten
0% und ganz selten 100%, es liegt irgendwo dazwischen, es könnte ja sein, dass zufälligerweise
mal jetzt hier so ein ding spawnt und man teil drin steckt, man weiß es ja nicht, aber
ich habe nicht vor damit irgendwelche erfahrungen zu machen in dieser richtung, gibt schon genug
leute, die so komische dinger machen, ich bin gestürzt, genau, ne, aber jetzt mal ernsthaft,
es gibt ja genug berichte darüber und es kommt auch jährlich oft genug vor, dass es
verletzungen mit staubsauger aller art gibt in dieser richtung, und da frage ich mich
immer, wer kommt ernsthaft auf die idee, dass es eine sinnvolle idee wäre, seinen teil
in staubsauger zu stecken, das frage ich mich jedes mal, wenn ich so statistik oder so berichte
lese, wie kommt man auf so eine idee, das sind genau die leute, die sich eine klübe
in den bobs schieben und sich dann denken, fuck, ich kriege die ja gar nicht mehr richtig
raus ohne, dass sie kaputt geht, kommt auch öfters mal vor, wo ich mir denke, was zum
teufel ist mit den leuten nicht richtig, warum, warum macht man sowas, egal, wir gucken uns
das video jetzt an, vor drei monaten habe ich euch bereits den
neun
meine katz
hat vor so ziemlich allem schiss nur witzigerweise vor dem staubsauger robotter nicht, ich weiß
nicht warum, der ist laut, der ist gefährlich, aber da setzten sie sich mit dem rücken dazu
hin, die hat sich wahnsinnig erschreckt das letzte mal, die ist ins wohnzimmer gegangen,
da ist der gerade rumgefahren und da hat sie sich auf den boden gesetzt, hat ihn erstmal
belauert und dann hat sie sich so hingesetzt, dass der von hinten an sie ran gefahren ist
und sie hat sich mitbekommen und da hat er ihr quasi so in den schwanz reingesaugt, der
robotter, ich hab meine katze noch nie aus dem stand so weit springen sehen wie jetzt,
die ist aus dem stand quasi halb die treppe runter gesprungen, irgendwie fünf meter, die
hat sich brutal erschreckt, seitdem ist sie da ein bisschen skeptischer bei dem ding,
hab ich euch bereits den neuen roborock s7 saugroboter vorgestellt, ihr erinnert euch,
schickes modernes design, starke saugleistung und mit dem feature b-saugleistung ist das
beste, um in einem arbeitsgang auf teppich zu saugen und hartböden gleichzeitig wischen
zu können, falls ihr das verpasst habt, schaut das bitte zuerst, ihr findet das video jetzt
oben rechts in den infokarten, heute geht es nämlich um die passende absaugstation,
die ab sofort erhältlich ist, anders als viele andere stationen arbeitet die vom s7
auf wunsch auch ohne beutel und bevor wir uns das genau anschauen, checken wir erstmal
den lieferumfang, im großen karton finden wir zuerst den quickstart guide, der reicht
für die simple handhabung zwar aus, eine ausführliche bedienungsanleitung, die ebenfalls
bei die absaugstation besteht aus zwei teilen, das unterteil ist mit 45 mal 30 zentimetern
stellfläche recht groß und sorgt dafür, dass der s7 anständig auffahren kann, die ladekontakte
dabei gesäubert werden und der schmutzt seinen weg vom roboter in den behälterlöschen.
das ist ja gerade der trick dabei, das ist ja quasi ein beutel, also gehe ich mal von
aus, so habe ich das auf bildern und vorstellungen davon gesehen, da kommt ja ein beutel rein,
man braucht dann aber halt kein beutel mehr im staubsauger, jetzt ist es halt so, du musst
das ding jedes mal, jedes zweite mal aber spätestens musst du den leeren, ansonsten
wird die saugleistung irgendwann kacke oder es geht gar nichts mehr rein. was wusstest
du, dass man bei einem repo das com mit def verwechselt, die repo in vias code im web geöffnet
wird, ne wusste ich nicht.
bei shithub, ne wusste ich nicht, jawoll schiebt den beutel ein, gibs mir, schiebt
den beutel rein, ja gut das ergibt sinn, das ergibt sinn, der alte beutel, der alte
behälter für den roborock hatte keine anschlussgeschichten für die absaugstation, ja ok, das ergibt
sinn.
iFatTime.
die absaugstation.
oh, aber ordentlich.
so, das war's, jetzt noch die zahlreichen schutzfolien abziehen und die station ist
einsatzbereit.
schraubendreher ist doch, ist doch ganz hyper korrekt, heißt ja auch so, wobei ich ja persönlich
auch lieber schraubenzier sag, außer ich weiß, dass ich mit jemand rede, der besonders pingelig
ist, was das angeht, dann sag ich auch schraubendreher, zum beispiel mit dem chat, wenn ich mit dem
chat rede, der mir sonst wieder vorwirft, ich würde critical information lacken, dann
sag ich schraubendreher.
walletudo supporte den s7, das problem ist die customfirma drauf zu bekommen, den musst
du aufmachen und selbst dinger dranlöten und sowas und das hab ich kein bock.
okay.
und gereinigt werden. Wie von Roborock gewohnt, alles mit einfachen Mechanismen und ohne viel
Rumgefummel. Das gilt übrigens auch für den Schmutzbehälter selbst. Dieser wird mit einem
ausklappbaren Henkel einfach von der Station gezogen und dieser rote Entriegelungsschalter
öffnet die Klappe unten zum Entleeren oder Wechseln der Einheiten. Der Filter für den
beutellosen Betrieb kann für die Reinigung herausgedreht werden. Insgesamt erinnert der
Aufbau stark an den Roborock H6 bzw. H7 Handakku Sauger, bei dem das Ganze bereits sehr gut
funktioniert hat. Ihr seht das hier, es ist quasi eine hochskalierte Version davon. Auch der Adapter
für den Beutelbetrieb wird wie beim H7 einfach mit dem Filter getauscht. Also das Handling macht easy Eindruck.
Der Beutelbetrieb macht vor allem für allergischer Sinn, da durch den automatischen Verschluss des
Beutels hier nahezu kein Kontakt mit dem Schmutz stattfindet. Ein Beutel reicht laut Hersteller
für bis zu acht Wochen Saugroboterbetrieb, wobei das natürlich je nach Haushalt variieren kann.
Ich persönlich ziehe den beutellosen Betrieb vor. Das spart zum einen Geld, da man keine Beutel
kaufen muss und schon zudem die Umwelt. Außerdem sieht es ziemlich fancy aus, wie der Schmutz beim
Absaugen in dem Behälter herumwirbelt. Das Ausleeren des Schmutzbehälters kann man wie hier gezeigt...
Das muss ich mir nochmal angucken, ob das wirklich fancy aussieht. Zeig mal her.
Und schon zudem die Umwelt. Außerdem sieht es ziemlich fancy aus, wie der Schmutz beim Absaugen in
dem Behälter herumwirbelt. Das Ausleeren des Schmutzbehälters kann man wie hier gezeigt einfach über
einem großen Mülleimer erledigen und außerdem sei der Sensor erwähnt, der erkennt, ob der
Schmutzbehälter eingesetzt ist oder nicht. Sollte man also mal vergessen den Behälter nach dem
Ausleeren einzusetzen, pustet die Station nicht unkontrolliert Staub in den Wohnraum.
Das ist gut. Das ist tatsächlich gut. Die bequemste ist der Automatikmodus.
Nach jedem Reinigungsvorgang... Ich glaube, das Verkratzen ist gar
nicht so das Problem. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sie da schon was halbwegs
resistentes genommen haben und damit das wirklich verkratzt wird,
da müsste das auch wirklich mit ordentlich Wumms da irgendwie, da kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Das wirbelt da ein bisschen rum, drückt vielleicht nach außen, aber das ist da
groß verkratzt, glaube ich nicht.
... wird der Schmutzbehälter automatisch an der Station entleert. Die Funktion kann in der App ein-
und ausgeschaltet und die Intensivität entsprechend eingestellt werden. Ich habe das hier einfach auf
Smart gelassen und die Station hat hier immer recht gut entschieden, wie stark und lang...
Aber wobei, das knallt da schon ganz schön dran.
Das ist ganz einfach, die müssen einfach einen Diamantbehälter nehmen.
... man kann den Absaugvorgang auch manuell starten. Das geht entweder ebenfalls über die App oder wenn
man die Home-Taste am Saugroboter selbst drückt, während er natürlich auf der Station steht.
Hier wird mit maximaler Saugkraft etwa 30 Sekunden...
Was ich aber gut finde ist, dass sie das wirklich eingehalten haben. Die haben gesagt,
ihr könnt euch den S7 kaufen und die Station wird auf jeden Fall kompatibel sein, auch wenn sie
erst ein halbes Jahr später rauskommt und es scheint wirklich zu stimmen.
Man kann sich das in etwa wie bei einem Kabelstaubsauger im Betrieb vorstellen.
Das Absaugen funktionierte sowohl manuell als auch mit der Automatik auf Smart wunderbar und
automatisiert den Betrieb des Saugroboters nochmal ein ganzes Stück mehr.
Die Ladestation funktioniert ähnlich wie die originale, allerdings steht sie durch das
deutlich höhere Gewicht natürlich sicherer auf dem Boden.
Die größere Fläche bietet zudem entsprechend strukturierte Auffallrampen und der S7 kann durch
das Vibra-Rise-Feature und der großen Fläche auch problemlos mit angestecktem Wischtuch auf
der Station stehen, ohne dass man sich Sorgen um zum Beispiel empfindlichen Holzboden machen muss.
Kleine Bürsten und Federmechanismen sorgen außerdem dafür, dass die Kontakte sauber sind und eine
sichere Verbindung zum Roboter haben. Der Kanal vom Roboter zur Station kann zur Reinigung übrigens
mit sieben Schrauben demontiert werden. Auch hier sind die Schrauben wieder gesichert,
sodass man diese nicht verlieren kann. Das Verlegen geht schnell und die Reinigung kann
je nach Bedarf durchgeführt werden. Am durchsichtigen Kanal kann jedenfalls leicht
erkannt werden, ob sich hier Schmutz festgesetzt hat.
Ja, ich muss sagen, ich finde das Ding cool. Richtiger Pock. Pock-Gadget.
Ja, was es kostet, bin ich nochmal gespannt. Weiß ich, hat er schon gesagt am Anfang, was es
kostet? Kommt bestimmt noch. 5 Billionen. Na dann, kann nix mehr schiefgehen.
Ui. Das heißt, die Station kostet ungefähr, nein das stimmt nicht ganz, aber so 30-40% vom
Staubsäure. Schon ordentlich. Ungefähr 1000 Euro. Ich würde sagen, im Angebot vielleicht
ein bisschen günstiger. Wir gucken mal. Aber so in dem Dreh auf jeden Fall. S7. So. Ach
echt, den gibt es doch 500 schon. Ne, das ist Debate. Sagen wir 550. Absaugstation.
550 und, ist das die Absaugstation? Bei Otto. Hä? Ne. Glaub, die kann man gar nicht kaufen
oder was? S7. Sogar die Computer-Build hat den Kram getestet. Ich finde, WTF viel zu
teuer. Also für den Preis lohnt sich das auf jeden Fall nicht. Das wäre mir dann doch
deutlich zu viel. Wo kann man den Kram kaufen? China? Ali? Ali Express? Vielleicht ein bisschen
teuer. Minimal teuer vielleicht. Ok. Warum ist das so teuer? Ok, das hier geht ja natürlich
dann schon eher. Aber warum soll ich das bei den China-Chinesen bestellen? Kann es sein,
das ist kein aktueller? Ja, leider. Also weil der Tudor unterstützt den S7. Das ist gar
kein Problem. Das Problem ist die Custom-Firma, die dafür nötig ist, drauf zu bekommen.
Und das liegt daran, weil die Hersteller das immer schwieriger machen. Ich meine gut,
ich verstehe es, dass man nicht als Hersteller es den Leuten einfach macht, Custom-Firma
drauf zu bekommen, weil das überhaupt nicht der Fokus ist. Das sollen Noobs bedienen
können und Noobs kaufen. Aber man muss es ihnen ja auch nicht super schwer machen, weil
die paar Leute, die sich das kaufen und Custom-Firma drauf machen, das sind jetzt ja wirklich
nicht die, die ihnen wieder groß das Geschäft kaputt machen, zumal die sich evtl. den Roboter
sogar nur kaufen, weil Custom-Firma möglich ist. Also das verstehe ich nicht. Wie gesagt,
beim S7 muss man auch Schrauben und Sachen anlöten. Kann ich euch mal kurz zeigen. Find
das Video dazu noch nicht mal? Ach ne, das war das S6, den wir gesehen haben, dass der
zu flashen geht, oder? Genau, guckt euch das mal an. Beim S6, den musst du komplett auseinander
bauen, du musst es komplett auseinander bauen und dann, also das Part 2, und dann musst
du das Mainboard rausnehmen, dort irgendwelche Kontakte anlöten. Also ich würde mir das
zwar prinzipiell zutrauen zu machen, aber ich habe keinen Bock auf die Arbeit. Ne, also
das muss echt nicht sein. So und ob man den S7 überhaupt flashen kann, bin ich mir gar
nicht sicher. Hier Tab, guckt mal mal. Roborock S7, Roborock S7. Schauen wir mal. Also unterstützen
tun sie den S7 schon? Aber wie bekommt man da die Firmware drauf? Das muss ich jetzt
mal nachgucken, S7. Wahrscheinlich gar nicht so einfach. Without root, ne, das wird nicht
funktionieren. Hier gibt es keine großartige Infos zu S7 root. Da gibt es wahrscheinlich
einfach gar keinen root für. Ja, guckt. Der wird zwar theoretisch unterstützt, aber wahrscheinlich
hat das noch nie jemand ausprobiert. Gibt keine root Methode, tja. RIP würde ich sagen.
Dann gibt es da auch nichts. Übrigens Leute, ini hatten wir mal im Stream den Programmierer
davon. Richtig poc. Der ist hier random mal im Chat aufgetaucht, wo wir lustigerweise auch
gerade seine GeTripus angeguckt haben. Vor 2-3 Monaten. Oh, wisst ihr, dass gleich Bad
ist? Ich kann noch mal schnell was schauen. Weil eine Sache wollte ich mir tatsächlich
wirklich noch bestellen. Die muss ich jetzt hier noch schnell in den Warenkorb rein machen.
Also wir haben ja alles drinne, was ich kaufen wollte. Lackierte Lackdrähte, Bluetech, die
sind nur Teil lackiert. Die sind nur Teil lackiert. Die badest mich jetzt wieder mit irgendwelchen
komischen Dingern. Was ich noch haben will, ist einen weiteren Schrank. So ein Kleinteile-Sortiment-Schrank.
Kleinteile-Magazin. Hat nichts mit Kona-Pistolen zu tun, sondern so ein Teil hier. Das ist sehr,
sehr praktisch. Da habe ich aktuell bei mir im Serverraum eins hängen. Vielleicht nehme
ich aber auch ein anderes diesmal. Vielleicht nehme ich auch das mit den ganz kleinen drinnen.
Das ist unglaublich praktisch. Habe ich jetzt schon bei mir im Serverraum hängen? Ich habe
ja da Werkzeug. Moment. Für alle, die es noch nicht gesehen haben, ich zeige das mal
schnell, wie es da aussieht. Hier Serverraum-Rundgang. Da habe ich hier unten steht der 3D-Drucker
und da unten drunter. Ich zeige es jetzt glaube ich gleich. Genau, 3D-Drucker und hier ist
das Rack mit Server-Switch und alle möglichen Gedöns drin. Hier ist die Werkzeug-Wand und
da an der Seite hängt diese Vera-Flex. Ja natürlich. Wer hat, der hat. Ja auf Max, komm. Hier.
Da sieht man es jetzt gleich. Aufschwenken. Guck da. Das Ding. Sehr praktisch. Ich habe
mittlerweile mein ganzes Kleinkram-Zeug sortiert. Das eine ist nahezu komplett voll mit irgendwelchen
Hohl-Steckern und Dingern in dieser Richtung. Dem anderen ist Schrumpf-Schläuche und Gedöns
drin. Dann habe ich mein ganzes Löt-Kram, Kleinkram-Zeug, was ich manchmal brauche.
Das ist sehr praktisch. Das ist wirklich praktisch. Deswegen habe ich mir jetzt überlegt, ich
habe noch so viel mehr Kleinkram, aber was was thematisch nicht unbedingt so gut zusammenpasst.
Also unterschiedlichste Bauteile und Sachen. Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, ich glaube,
ich kaufe mir diesmal den hier, der noch kleiner, der klar so groß ist, noch kleinere Fächer
hat, weil ich habe da auch nicht so viele Teile von und den hänge ich hier daneben. Da ist
nämlich noch Platz hier nebendran. Druck ihn dir doch einfach aus. Ja, Pfeifert, genau.
Ich habe letztens was gedruckt, siebeneinhalb Stunden. Ich zeige euch mal, was ich gedruckt
habe. Vielleicht hattet ihr mal eine Idee, wie ich das noch retten kann. So, ich habe
nämlich ausgedruckt den Halterung für den Stromzähler von ihm hier. Da. Hier, das Teil
habe ich ausgedruckt. Da hier vorne kommt der ESP mit der Kamera rein. Und das hier
macht man dann quasi an den Stromzähler. Sieht dann zwar nicht schön aus, aber man
kann ihn ablesen. So, und ich habe das ausgedruckt im 3D Drucker. Und wer sowas schonmal 3D gedruckt
hat, dem wird wahrscheinlich jetzt auffallen, da sind so Bögen und Brücken drinnen. Die
kann man ja mit einem 3D Drucker prinzipiell nicht drucken. Ein 3D Drucker druckt layer
auf layer. Das heißt, eine Brücke kann ich auf einem 3D Drucker nicht drucken. So, das
heißt, was man dazu machen muss, dass das ganze funktioniert, der 3D Drucker muss hier
quasi so Stützpfeiler bauen, dass er das drucken kann. So, und ich habe dieses Teil
jetzt gedruckt und es ist jetzt voll mit Füllmaterial. Das hat hier hinten quasi eine komplette Wand
aus Füllmaterial und hier auch so dick an beiden Seiten Füllmaterial. Wie kriege ich
denn das wieder weg? Ich habe das versucht rauszubrechen und es bricht ja gar nicht am
Stück ab. Das kriegst du gar nicht richtig sauber. Auf dem Bild hat er es aber doch
90 Grad gedreht, gedruckt. Wo? Hier? Dann hast du hier hinten doch das gleiche Problem.
Der hat, der druckt das hochkant. Äh ne, der druckt das, der druckt das so wie das
hier liegt. Ach so, stimmt. Ne, aber guck mal, hier ist es so. Aber hier ist es so.
Aber du kannst es auch gar nicht hochkant richtig drucken, weil hier unten hast du ja
diese Bommel. Das hier ist ein zweiter Teil. Also ich gehe davon aus, der hat das so gedruckt.
Ja, das stelle ich mir schwierig zum drucken vor, ist es auch. Man sieht das übrigens
auch bei ihm im Video, wie er das druckt. Nur mal für alle, die das für mich glauben.
Man sieht das auch im Video, wie er das druckt. Hier. Guck mal, das ist eindeutig, dass der
das so druckt. Er druckt das so, das sieht man ja hier. Er druckt das auch mit Support.
Guck, er druckt das auch mit Support. Hier hinten ist das Ding. Also das ist wirklich
sehr eklig. So und ich habe das komplett voll mit Support und Füllkram, den ich jetzt
gar immer richtig rauskriege. Also Eats rausbrechen ist da auf jeden Fall nichts. Ne, das ist
so ein Reason Drucker oder sowas mit Hearts. Das kannst du eh in Indoor nicht einsetzen,
es sei denn der Drucker hat eine luftdichte Verkleidung und du hast irgendeine Absaugung
dafür. Das ist giftig das Zeug. Also das kannst du dir eh nicht ins Haus stellen. Da
muss das Seitenschneider her. So einfach ist das gar nicht. Ich habe das versucht raus
zu bekommen, aber das kriegt man nicht. Richtig raus. Luft anhalten, sieben Stunden. Viel Spaß.
World Record Incoming. Hammer, da machst du ja auch die anderen Sachen kaputt. Du kannst
Support Strukturen rausbrechen, das ist kein Problem, aber nur wenn sie dünn sind. Guck
mal, guck mal wie dick der Support hier ist. Siehst du das? Das hier. Das ist alles Support,
das ist alles Support was du hier siehst. Das eigentliche ist ja so. Also sprich, das
hier ist alles Support. Das einzige was am Ende noch da bleibt, ne noch nicht einmal,
das einzige was am Ende noch da bleibt ist dann so der hintere Bogen irgendwie. Also
er drückt hier auch mit massig Support. Ich gehe mal davon aus das muss man manuell tunen.
Oder aber was anderes, ich werde es zum testen einfach so machen. Ich nehme einfach ein Lineal
und hänge das da dran vor den Stromzähler. Runter und gucke erstmal ob es funktioniert.
Übrigens, er hat auch hier so Big Brain lackierte Kabel. Oder ich habe es noch nicht gecheckt
wie ich das besser einstellen kann. Hast du einen Dremel? Ja, habe ich. Was mit Finger
Fräser? Was für ein Ding? Gute Frage. Ich habe mir mal so eine Toolbox gekauft mit einigen
Dingern drin. Keine Ahnung ob da sowas dabei ist. Muss ich mal ausprobieren. Aber wenn
ich dann anfange rumzuschnibbeln mit dem Dremel, dann fliegen die Fetzen und ich schneide wahrscheinlich
irgendwas ab was ich noch brauche. Oh, Bedgetime. Ich sehe es gerade. Chat, ich finde das äußerst
nett von euch, dass ihr mich daran erinnert, dass ich jetzt ins Bett muss. Sehr zuvorkommend.
Ich würde sagen ich lasse jetzt mal das Outro laufen und suche mal jemand den ich hausten
kann. Zeig mal her, wen können wir denn hausten? Ist jemand am Start? Cyrus haben wir gestern
gehostet. Semper Video haben wir davor gehostet. Moment. Ist das nicht bei uns immer im Chat
oder? Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das streamt. Das ist ja witzig. Was macht der denn? Der
ist doch immer bei uns im Stream. Sonntags auch und so. Den hosten wir jetzt. Bam. Nice.
Passiv oder wir reden besser gesagt. Raiden. Der ist teilweise im Stream, während er selber
streamt. Das ist ja mal richtig Feifett Aktion. Massivster 5 Kopf. Ach ja. Schön, dass ihr
wieder mit dabei gewesen seid. Wir sehen uns. Morgen nehme ich schon mal ein Video auf zum
neuen Battlefield. Ich werde darüber auslassen, ob die ganzen der Ultra Hype Train aktuell
gerade gerechtfertigt ist. Bis denn. Badge. Wir sehen uns. See you.